ma la musica normale in un cazzo di
videogame che riescono a mettere per
cortesia questi ragazzi pervenute questo
nuovo sono pari j
ci siamo su player versus game sarebbe
tipo un range game solo che allora
partiamo perché perché è triste player
uno che cosa c'è di strano io che sono
questo tizio che sembra ash dei pokémon
devo prenderla moneta questa qui e
portarla indietro alla slot machine
prima che il gioco mi fermi cioè nel
senso il gioco stesso tenta di fermarti
ci sono quattro livelli ragazzi mi pare
quindi facciamo il primo partiamo da
altri ecco cos'è sta roba che cazzo
cazzo hai bevuto cose ubriacona costa
sud calmi calvi qual è la slot machine
perfetto su un campo gioca su un casco
che bordello ai ragazzi novara non si
capisce la mazza sono riuscito non ci
posso credere
devo arrivare prima di tutto al check
point che quello che sta lì l'ho preso
l'ho presto ce l'ho fatta regalo o
almeno questo l'ho preso new haven
glitch e non c'è stato un errore non
sappiamo di che cosa si tratta
ma sappiamo che non possiamo risolverlo
e tutto ciò che puoi fare è ricominciare
la tua vita riscontro l'alt fp tab
cooper romperti il dito i droidi zio
equity ma sei serio il gioco ma
[ __ ]
calmiamoci macedone è una roba io l'ho
mai vista una roba del genere in un
videogioco ragazzo c'è fini va beh provo
a farlo tutta la veloce ragazzi perché
non è che possono stare qua vita mi
chiamò movado anche al contrario fotte
sega forte sega se ho preso l'ho presa
sua maestà ragazzi c a manetta via race
e touch e credo che questo e credo che
credo che sono un [ __ ] credo che
condanni via alla fine quella roba lì
con teschio io io muoio perché arriva a
glik credo non lo so non sono sicuro non
ci credo ragazzi ho tutto nel culo è
ciao ciao prima guerra ma incontra in
italia arriva così in ritardo zio fatti
due calcoli
siamo al 2 ragazzi mancano 13 già posso
io so che allora mi avete detto che tra
l'altro è uno dei giochi più difficili
degli ultimi mesi ed effettivamente non
è così semplice però cazzo senza farli
tutti
stavo scherzando se riesco a farli tutti
voglio un premio
delle banane [ __ ] però qua rossi
cadono a caso a caso
non c'è un motivo ci cascano minchia va
basta ok come lo schivato ragazzo ti sei
incazzato che ti ho chiamato trenitalia
non è che deve incazzare è uscito subito
spiegatemi come dovrei far dai ragazzi
ma se di serie a porca [ __ ] vasca
live
[Musica]
piano siamo a metà ma perché no non ho
ucciso
elogia ok ok dove stavamo eccola dai vai
vai vai vai del nonno genere era sempre
quello che era sempre quelli
luca luca sul cambio fi nell'immenso del
to the faith declich livello tre ragazzi
non so perché c'è un tentacolo delle
dimensioni di rocco siffredi l'altro
ragazzi il gioco stesso si dice quando
ci manda i gleek c'è il si ricaricano in
lizza adesso arriva all ag che questo ok
le fa sopra soppresso sopra la panca tua
madre campo
il problema non è non è il check point
problema è che quando ai check point non
arrivi comunque da nessuna parte perché
c'è l'inglese che ti in groppa le
famiglie lei la moneta in sta cazzo di
gioco murum di cui il modugno per
cortesia per l'amor di dio che cazzo di
problemi ai ha bloccati neanche le gare
sono e neanche gleeks bloccato tutto il
gioco
ecco perché sto giocano emerga foto
markets c'è scritto markets ditelo pure
il mio computer ci si mette la non è
neanche il glitch del gioco come
computer mio ma perché devono rompere i
[ __ ] sti cosi bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye sono un deficiente ecco la
zona mira che madonna madonna come ci
arrivo
l'ho preso se si cela uno taci tu a
cominciar i voli sopra
così si
no non così entro è troppo è troppo alto
come spiega così ok ok no no no no no no
no no no no mi cazzo mi incazzo
non ci credo mai non donna madonna dove
sono gesu markets detto sì si resta
parte già è difficile e va bene una
volta qui come cazzo
guardatelo saltare prima da zio coste
pause ok ok ok ma posso concludere quel
video raga vi prego non voglio fare
l'ultimo sono db supplico proviamo siamo
arrivati all'ultimo ragazzi non so come
non so come ma siamo arrivati all'ultimo
proviamoci
l'ultimo a canna ok ok e fin qua dove
vado cosa faccio
di qua e vabbè datte na calmata
ok non si può stimare ma neanche volendo
dai zio taci tu a ma perché per mentre
glitch lampeggia c'è scritto pizza già
scritta pizza questo è esagera e peggio
di tutti gli altri messi insieme parola
o fatta come ho fatto
ok non me ne frega niente avere così ce
la fai a fare un salto di saltare bene
bravo bravo bravo è sì sì sì
dovendo no salta salta la moneta e lì ok
dato a sinistra avrò dice freccia e
ditelo non finire offrire fine no non ci
credo mai
se non fossero le 10 del mattino e che
sono un po addormentato mi sarei
incazzato ancora di più ok perfetto
cosa ho schivato cosa scriva dovrai solo
madonna se morivo così ok e non a caso
sono morto non posso ciclisti cazzo
veloce fi veloce faillace fi della filef
ai fatti tua madre
io ebbe invece cosa vuoi che ti dica se
sei stronzo posso concludere qui lo
stesso prego sei veloce veloce prima che
mori veloce dai zio la moneta porca eva
dov'è eccola veloci indietro però c'è
dell'altro
no non devi morire zio sam wo perso ok
guarda in faccia nessuno bye bye bye bye
bye non prendono anche c'è poi è bravo
[ __ ] no no no cazzo sono vivo sono
vivo non so come proprio lusso come
veloce no io sì o sì o sì o ti ammazzo
solo questo bravo bravo bravo bravo
ecco non hai centrato il buco di
ricentrare il buco frate lo so che è
difficile per decentrare i buchi ma
centrale
se sei dovrei pensare un po di più alla
[ __ ] già povere ragazzi è stata basta
guarda io io giocherei ancora molto
volentieri cioè mi ha divertito tanto e
per carità di dio sono però ci basta
proprio così meno di mimì us pontedecimo
vi ringrazio per avermi consigliato
questa merda di gioco e ha fatto gesù
markets non sapevo franco io quindi
ragazzi spero che i video vi sia
piaciuto spenderò palco io oggi ho
battuto il gioco non lo voglio più fare
mai nella vita però sta è stato
traumatico però l'ho fatto con i ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto e cosa il 2018
suo commento è un mi piace anche a
faccia di facebook che come nei video
trattando iscrizione o un mi piace se
anche voi siete più forti dei giochi
stessi perché i giochi sono persone
cattive cityscape ci vediamo al prossimo
video ai ragazzi